depending on how well you want to do and
particularly if you're starting a
company you need to work super hard
so what what does super heart mean the
core
of of what really matters that we are
the same
you know how i know that because all of
us are seeking the same thing
if you don't have you know kids that you
need to
uh support you know it's a very low risk
thing wanna be happy live a life not
just a business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you're
capable of more
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn the best lessons
from
elon musk jeff bezos warren buffett and
other billionaires
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one work super hard with elon musk
you need to work if depending on how
well you want to do and particularly if
you're starting a company you need to
work super hard so
what what does super hard mean well
when my brother and i were starting our
first company uh instead of getting an
apartment we just
rented a small office and we slept on
the couch
and we showered at the the ymca and
uh we're so hot up we had just one
computer so
the the the website was up during the
day
uh and i was coding at night seven days
a week
all the time um and i i uh
sort of briefly had a girlfriend in that
period and in order to
be with me she had to sleep in the
office so
i work hard like
it i mean every waking hour that's
that's the the thing i would i would say
if you particularly if you're starting a
company um
and i mean if you do simple math say
like okay if somebody else is working
50 hours and you're working 100 you'll
get twice as done
as much done in the course of a year as
the other company
rule number two pursue the highest
expression of yourself with oprah
winfrey
i always understood that there really
was no difference between me and the
audience
at times i might have had better shoes
but at the core
the core of of what really matters
that we are the same and you know how i
know that because
all of us are seeking the same thing
you're here at this
fabulous school and will go out into the
world
and each pursue based upon what you
believe your talents are
what your skills are maybe your gifts
are
but you're seeking the same thing
everybody wants to fulfill
the highest truest expression
of yourself as a human being
that's what you're looking for the
highest
truest expression of yourself as a human
being
and because i understand that i
understand that if you're working in a
bakery
and that's where you want to be and that
may be that that may be what you've
always wanted to do is to bake
pies for people or bake cakes for people
or to offer your
gift then then that's that's for you and
there's no difference between you and me
except that's how that's your platform
that's your show every day so my
understanding of that
has allowed me to you know everyone to
reach everyone
and and there's no way that you wouldn't
because that's that's what i
truly feel rule number three take
calculated risks with bill gates
urgency that i felt that if we didn't
get microsoft going right away that
somebody
uh would do a great job building a
software company we won't have a chance
that probably
ended up not being true that i could
have waited two or three years and the
opportunity to do microsoft still would
be there but anyway i felt a sense of
urgency
uh and you know it's not like you know i
still get to take courses and learn
things um today you know things like the
learning company and there's all sorts
of great books so
it's not like i've missed some part of
my education
when you dropped out your father and
mother said are you sure you know what
you want to do if
one of your children dropped out of
college to start a company what would
you say
well i'd have to say yes but the
dropping out is not an irrevocable
decision
uh you know if you try and start a
company it doesn't go well they always
let you go back
uh and so if you don't have
you know kids that you need to uh
support
you know it's a very low risk thing
particularly in the
culture of the united states where
trying to start something and
and failing is not a black mark for the
rest of your life
rule number four be stubborn on your
vision with jeff bezos be stubborn on
vision and flexible on details
the you really can't accomplish anything
important if you're not stubborn on
vision because things that are important
take a long time
you take teams you can't do it by
yourself and so you really
need to you need to have a crisp idea of
the vision
you need to stay incredibly relentless
on that vision
but you need to be flexible on the
details because
you've got to be experimental to
accomplish anything important
and that means you're going to be wrong
a lot and so you're going to try
something
on your way to that vision and that's
going to be the wrong thing the wrong
decision you're going to have to back up
take a little course correction and try
again
and so you cannot be stubborn on the
details
you have to be flexible on the details
also if you want to have more self love
confidence and learn from billionaires
check out my 254 series they're free
the links to join are in the description
below for people who didn't get the love
they need
no matter where it is you grew up you
spend the rest of your life trying to
fill that thing
i'm a weird dropout because i take
college courses all the time
i love learning company courses and
and things so i love being a student the
biggest risk you can take
is not taking any risk rule number five
have the right heroes with warren
buffett the most important thing
aside from the things i've talked about
already is it's really who you associate
with you want to associate with people
that are better than you are
i mean basically you'll go in the
direction of the people that you
associate with and
and you want to have the right heroes uh
you want people
if you want to emulate somebody you
better pick very carefully who you want
to emulate and
and when obviously you can't pick your
parents
uh they're gonna have enormous influence
on you but you don't get a choice on
that but you get choices as you go down
the line and you
who you uh who you admire who you who
who you want to copy and the most
important
for most people in terms of that
decision is their spouse it's also
important in terms of a partner in
business but the partner in life is
is the most important one you want to
pick a spouse that's a little that's
better than you are
and then he or she and you hope they
don't figure it out too fast
rule number six focus long term with
mark zuckerberg
what do you think the three keys to your
success are well i think a lot of it
goes back to those values right i mean
the values often come from
the founder the person running the
company so i think i believe those
things probably the most strongly of of
people at the company
um yeah move fast be bold right um
focus on impact and i think um
you know i think long-term focus is is a
really important part of this and we've
had a lot of opportunities to optimize
for
the shorter term whether it's in selling
the company or doing
different products that would have
benefited us in the short term but not
optimized for the long term impact
then um and i just think you know
opportunities like this don't come
around that often so when
you get one i feel like you almost have
a duty to see it through and build it to
be
what it can be and rule number seven the
last one before a very special bonus
clip
is believe in your vision with jack ma
if jackman can be successful
succeed 80 percent of the young people
can be successful
we don't have money we don't have a
relationship
i don't have a powerful rich father even
though we don't have a rich father or
uncle
they can sponsor us everything we do
is the 18 funders we believe the future
we make progress even among the 18
founders
we only have three engineers amount of
three engineers
only one of them had a three years
experience at university
static computer the other two
they are like amateur computer they when
they open it they don't know how to fix
it
[Music]
start from there to today we have 25
000 engineers in our company
and nobody come to buy and sell
for the first two weeks terrible we
build our e-commerce company
nobody come to sell so we have to list
our own products on there
wait for two weeks nobody come to buy so
we have to buy ourselves
and then the first first month
some people come to sell things on our
site we buy everything so we buy a whole
house of rubbish
for the whole house we started nobody
believed
e-commerce until today or last year
we sold 550 billion u.s dollars
from nothing to 550 billion dollars
and i think compared to yesterday was
big sales
but compared to 10 years later we are
nothing
this is what i want to say the great
ideas i heard in the next room
in spite of me and changed mine
you are guys at the hope of africa
and i believe 15 years ago 13 year
18 years in my apartment i told my team
we are the hope
of china because we are the guys without
any resources
if we can make it the most people can
make it
if most people like us without the money
was our resources
only with the dream and belief if we can
make succeed
china will be successful now i've got a
really special bonus clip that i think
you're going to enjoy
but before that it's time for the
question of the day i want to know
what was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and what are you going
to do
to take action on it this week when you
write down
what day what time and what place you're
going to take action on something you
have a 91
chance of following through versus just
35
if you got motivated but never wrote
down a plan
and when you share your plan and have
public accountability it raises your
chances of following through
even higher so that's what i want to do
today for you guys
you watch this video what was your
single biggest takeaway and what
is your plan to take action on it this
week
let me know put it down in the comments
below you almost have to have that drive
like in other words you can't fake it
you can't
like pretend that you want to read about
ted turner and
okay i'll skip one movie your soul
yeah i mean you can fake it to make it
in a lot of areas particularly if you're
working for somebody else but at the end
of the day
um if you're going to be great at
something you've got to make the effort
to be great at something
whether it's sports whether it's physics
math
science business whatever it may be
you know it's not just a natural skill
you've got you've got to
to learn and particularly if you're in
the technology industry because it
changes every day
you know when i got started and and
you know after i got i got it i was a
bartender when i first came to dallas
got
into the pc industry got fired started
my own company
but there i learned early on that there
was always something new
and most people didn't put in the time
to learn it
it's like now with artificial
intelligence lots of people talk about
artificial intelligence
lots of people talk about machine
learning and neural networks not a lot
of people are putting in the time to
take classes or
do the tutorials or to to learn how to
apply it to business and
that's what it takes and and you know
that's just something i've always
enjoyed so that i've been fortunate
[Music]
if you want to change your life for free
in the next 30 days
check the link right here below me or if
you want seven more lessons from
billionaires check out my video right
there next to me
i think you'll enjoy them continue to
believe and i'll see you there